um
regardless of whether you believe
vaccines work
uh which they do
uh or whether covid is likely to be
serious in any particular population
about which we have different data like
regardless of all of those disagreements
that some people have not using fact to
come to conclusions
uh most everybody would agree if if you
have kova you should stay home right
like you even people who don't want to
get vaccinated mostly believe
covet exists it's contagious and you
should stay home when you have coveted
former republican congresswoman michelle
bachmann
is now praising
sarah palin for going out to restaurants
when she was contagious and infected
with kovid last week
so we're going to look at that just as a
reminder sarah palin was seen dining at
a manhattan restaurant elio's italian
restaurant in the upper east side
she had covet at the time
you may remember that the timeline was
and now i i want to make sure i have the
timeline right
she um tested positive for kovid i
believe it was january 23rd sunday the
23rd she had been out to eat in new york
on saturday the 22nd and then she was
seen within the five day period during
which you're not supposed to be out she
was seen in the middle of last week on
wednesday uh out dining at restaurants
we actually had uh that clip for you
last week we're just going to take a
look at a little bit of it here with
with no audio i'll describe what we're
seeing you see sarah palin sitting at a
restaurant one of these like indoor
outdoor outdoor indoor type scenarios
this also raised the question this
technically is outside but a few days
earlier she had reportedly been indoors
at this restaurant and new york does
require proof of vaccination to dine
indoors the question is is she actually
vaccinated but she's been lying that
she's not
or did the restaurant just not check for
the vaccination okay whatever the case
may be
so
michelle bachmann is interviewed on fox
news and she says we should be
commending sarah palin for being out
with covid
that's what she said take a look has
different reactions to it but i think
honestly sarah palin is to be commended
because she's trying to act like a
normal human being in the greatest city
in america in new york city she's going
out to eat at a wonderful little
boutique italian restaurant it has
different reactions so that's the view
she should be commended for it now i
wonder like prior to covet right when
during flu season
if michelle bachmann found out
that a republican was out with the flu
eating at restaurants would they say
that's a great heroic thing to do wow we
should we should really commend her for
being out uh
with the flu that that's a really great
thing
this is getting more and more stupid
every day
and i don't think it's gonna turn around
uh uh soon some people said well this is
darwinism at its finest it's really not
because darwinism would be that this
behavior kills off palin before she's
able to reproduce she's got kids already
so unfortunately it's not darwinism it
might just spread the virus to other
people at the restaurant who did nothing
wrong
um but now i mean it it's gotten so
backwards that they are now cheering
people who go out with a highly
contagious virus to restaurants that's
the rock bottom that we have now hit